hello everyone and welcome back to the
show that is always free but
so good you'll be saying i'd buy that
for a dollar
yeah unfortunately today's matchup is
not
that classic sitcom taking on cheers but
if you want to go where everybody knows
your name you can stop into a friendly
boston bar
or you can just be one of these super
successful cinematic cyborgs
battling it out for technological
supremacy robocop
versus terminator and while the two
themselves will not be performing any
hand-to-hand combat like they did in
those cool dark horse comics
or the badass super nintendo game best
birthday present ever
thank you mom this ball game will be
betwixt the two original movies that
launched their respective franchises
in one corner you have james cameron's
the terminator
starring linda hamilton michael bean and
some weightlifter playing a terrorizing
titan from the future
in the other corner is paul verhoeven's
robocop in which old detroit
isn't policed by bill wan beer or barry
sanders but by
an entity that's part man part machine
all cop
it's a tussle chock full of cybernetic
muscle and by the end
it'll probably look like when you go
behind your old fat back tv and look at
all those mess of wires random ikea
screws and electrical tape
here's how we'll determine a winner
round one box office
round two tomato meter slash audience
score round three
characters round four iconic moments
and then we'll do a wild card round in
which we could see which
robot thing has the cooler vision panel
terminator
has heat signatures but robocop can
press record and tape your favorite
shows
or i might just consider where the
franchises have gone
since their epic rookie debuts but for
now i know where i'm going
that are alive you are coming with me um
yeah you're gonna have me back in time
for dinner i'll be back
okay couldn't even make it to round one
without putting that joke in the script
let's get it on round one box office
like many of you at first blush i
thought there's no way robocop can
compete with the time traveling
versatility of a t-800
and i'm hungry i think this guy's a
couple can short of a six-pack
but then i realized we're just battling
between 1984 as the terminator
and 1987's robocop and then i thought oh
we got us a ball game and i'm still
hungry so now
after i ate it's anyone's game to win as
long as that anyone is at least half of
a robot with lots of r-rated action
despite the motion picture association
of america's rating
both films crushed at the domestic box
office
yes kids before deadpool we did have
other successful movies that you all
somehow were able to see way too young
when the terminator hit theaters in 1984
orion pictures
didn't market it all that heavily as
they perceived the project to not be in
their
fine cinema wheelhouse but once the
public got their hands on it
arnold schwarzenegger became an
international sensation
and the film grossed 103 million dollars
in theaters across the usa
yep the film that originally came to
director james cameron as a weird vision
of
kitchen knives attacking him in a
nightmare was now a certifiable hit
and it also spawned the inevitable
copycat robot based films to capitalize
on that marketplace
not the least of which was robocop and
while paul verhoeven does credit the
terminator as being an
influence on murphy and his ocp
struggles once that film came out in
1987
it took on a markedly different tone
than it's step
daddy i'm sure it's only a glitch so the
terminator is a futuristic time
traveling sci-fi action horror hybrid
but robocop tosses brutal violence and
social commentary into the blender
adds a dash of satire with a pinch of
humor to round out the recipe
it eventually made a winning formula as
the original robocop
grossed 125 million dollars in domestic
theaters
perhaps the most shocking part of both
film's success is how quickly they were
able to permanently cement themselves
into pop culture war
our rating be damned these two movies
almost immediately started moving
merchandise including toys
aimed at the use of the 80s well i will
point out that overall the terminator
sequels improved on its mint-making
ability
well for a while anyway and robocop's
follow-up films and remake had
diminishing box office returns
round one is a competition between the
two originals and thus
it is alex murphy and his tj laser gun
twirl winning round number one
and getting on the board first one to
nothing
pretty neat round two tomato meter slash
audience score if the sheer size of
arnold or the gratuitous usage of blood
in robocop surprised you
well prepare to now be shocked both
films are as
dominant as their title characters are
on the tomato meter
it's true that a terminator or robocop
may never be nominated for best picture
although i'd rather rewatch them than
amadeus or the last emperor
critics still fond over the dystopian
settings and captivating lead characters
just like the rest of us robocop stands
tall with 90
certified fresh in the tomato meter if
only it could loan some of that to
robocop
three which is just south of that at um
six percent rotten mr blutarsky
6.0 i award it no points and may god
have mercy on its soul
but again we're just looking at part
ones here so i was just making fun of
robocop 3 for no reason
and 90 is a tall order to topple
even for a cyborg hiding underneath
living breathing exoskeleton
but this t800 is up to the task as the
terminator has done the unthinkable
it's a perfect 100 percent even john
connor from the future
couldn't have foreseen that wow toy
story toy story 2
and the terminator all perfect 100
good luck at those mixers buzz lightyear
i think i have to go to be fair i will
also now highlight
the low light of the terminator
franchise its terminator jenny smith
resting at a rotten 27
both terrible movies and their canons
rebound somewhat on the audience score
as robocop 3
improves to 14 and jenny smith isn't
even the lowest terminator film on that
metric
no no that honor is reserved for part
three rise of the machines
which is just 46 it's almost like
audiences didn't buy the fact that
claire danes
suddenly remembers she can fly a plane
two hours into the movie
huh but the ogs remain strong and
competitive on the audience metric
robocop's percentage matches the year
that its opponent was born
84 while the terminator still gets the
honor roll credit at 89 percent
it's about as close as these two
franchises would get until we get the
crossover
anyone listening i know studio execs
love my show and i'm just begging y'all
on behalf of us fans give us robocop
versus terminator
please you're telling me alien can fight
predator and kramer can battle kramer
but these two a-list hunks can't duke it
out
and maybe give robocop three strokes he
needs it
for funsies arnold's pet franchise
dwarves peter wellers the rest of the
way
all of the terminator films average a
still fresh 65
on the tomato meter meanwhile the extra
robocops weigh that average down to 49
it's almost like having an
eight-year-old drug kingpin
didn't work huh the terminator is going
to take this round back to the future
with him and gets a game-tying win
in round two come with me if you want to
live
round three characters this next round
will feature
all of the weed side ancillary and cameo
rolls
in each film obviously we couldn't just
call it villains because arnold is the
bad guy and we couldn't call it heroes
because robocop is much more heroic than
anything in the huh what's oh right
sarah connor i'm sorry i totally messed
up that pronunciation
sarah khanna sarah khanna linda
hamilton's performance as the damsel in
distress turned
hero defending the future of humanity
had to hit all the right notes to take
our attention
off of schwarzenegger's biceps and boy
did she ever any list that ranks
cinematic female heroes is going to have
sarah connor close to the top
as a matter of fact we've actually done
a versus where her and ellen ripley take
it down to the wire
but leaving gender roles aside sarah
stands tall as a true 1980s icon
working jobs just to make ends meet and
now she was this robot sent back from
the future hell-bent on the single
purpose of trying to kill her
mondays am i right right luckily sarah
also has michael bean's turn as kyle
reese
who's also from the future and is sent
back in time with
more than one purpose protect sarah from
the bad guys sure but also if um
you're not doing anything later i mean
i'm single
uh spike right much more than just a
crucial plot point for the eventuality
named
john connor kyle reese represents all of
us who've ever had to maintain the
semblance of control in a situation but
inside
we're freaking the f out and if you're
not sure who michael bean is
go watch any 80s or 90s action movie
ever trust me he's there dude makes a
great navy seal
as complicated as kyle's trip back to
the 1980s must have been
a similar complexity has emerged in alex
murphy's life
you see peter weller's character wasn't
always some machine police officer
hybrid
he was just a new cop walking a beat
with his buddy lewis played by the
wonderful nancy allen
then when you know it a gaggle of nerd
duels funded by ocp
and led by kurtwood smith's clarence
botticker proceed to torture
and shoot alex approximately 5 000 times
they take a break and then light them up
30 000 more times just to be safe
it's only then that old bob morton
finally has a candidate to be part of
his new experimental robocop program
and while robocop still has some work to
do to get his sea legs
his debut goes a little better than his
cyber nemesis
ed209 uh that was a weird afternoon
at that office
but this round is about some of those
characters not mentioned in the title
and nancy allen's lewis provides a
stable center
to the ultra violent satirical chaos
surrounding her
ronnie cox's dick jones is largely
responsible for that chaos
and him being in cahoots with botticker
is an underrated aspect of this movie
they're really fun villains to watch
clarence with the one-liners
jones with the slick menacing plans for
the city it's a formidable duo for the
murph to take on
take a look at my face dick however the
most interesting character aspect of
robocop
is him wrestling with his own demons his
brain may have been in a body on life
support
but the memories of his family come
rushing back unannounced and wreak havoc
on his ability to
execute his orders executing orders is
something the terminator
is pretty good at and he's great at
executing people
i mean his name's the terminator
setting the tone for future villains who
are big on violence small on words like
say anton chaguer
arnold schwarzenegger took weapons
training for months in order to get down
his pattern so well
it looked like he was an actual machine
when they were wielded in either hand
plus those sunglasses that is peak 1980s
badassery
they even look good driving around a uh
2020 ford fusion
despite arnold matriculating in his
action career the terminator works
primarily because of our ability to
connect and identify with sarah connor
we as an audience understand where she
is in life we feel her fear
of an unstoppable villain and her
confusion as she develops feelings for
rhys over the course of the movie
and whereas the film's effects might not
live up to say
modern jim cameron standards the
characters themselves
resonate as timeless luckily so because
you know
whole movies about time travel both
films provide a combustible mix of
dynamic heroes and filthy evil doers but
it's the singular threat of an
all-time box office legend and the
spectrum of human emotion jogged by his
targets that inches the terminator
above robocop in this round the t800
gets the w
and is now up two to one that's right
this is [ __ ] great round four iconic
moments
movies are fun franchises are funner
which is not a word and funnest
is definitely not in webster's
dictionary but if it was
they might see a picture of the great
moments these two films have given us
over the years
perhaps it would be the tongue-in-cheek
image of a brand new 6000
s-u-x the preferred vehicle of bad guys
in robocop
or it might simply be the iconic image
of arnold a stone
cold robotic assassin from another time
wearing sunglasses that were certainly
not bought at a gas station
not that there's anything wrong with
that long after the lights have gone up
it's the moments we remember from these
two flicks that keep us
hungry for more and in the specific
cases of robocop and terminator
give the studio execs confidence to
green light multiple sequels
for terminator although he didn't have a
ton of dialogue arnold made the most of
his on-screen chatter
you're close give them to me
is exactly how a robot might demand
suitable 1980s attire and
if said robot was murderous you would
expect to see epic violence like the
melee the police station
or when that robot is horrifically
resurrected
proving to be a seemingly indestructible
force but if it's iconic lines you want
nothing can top i'll be back what could
have been a throwaway line became the
bat signal of the franchise
spawning multiple iterations and dozens
of callbacks in other movies
however the two moments that stand out
the most to this guy
who is technically from the future if
you're sarah connor in 1984
is when her and kyle reese team up to
defeat arnold once and for all
or at least until 1992
they lure him into a trap after blowing
him up then squish him to a pulp in a
move that surely inspired casey jones to
do a similar move to the shredder
in 1990s teenage mutant ninja turtles
yes
i remember that movie well oops
the influence of james cameron's
terminator is clearly evident in paul
bearhoven's robocop
as alex murphy doesn't have a whole lot
to say once he becomes a cybernetic
organism with trace amounts of humanity
left over
and while it may not be as instantly
recognizable as i'll be back
that are alive you are coming with me is
just as
cool in my humble opinion and again i'm
from the future
seeing the badass image of robocop
walking through a gas station fire to
clip an air dewell on his motorcycle
or watching him get the ultimate revenge
on a pervert must have made audiences
cheer in the theater
and for that last part maybe make dudes
grab their crotch just out of sheer
reflex
the climactic clash of robocop versus ed
209 is a hoot but it's ed's
first scene that is actually the most
memorable he's introduced as a new
police force in a stuffy corporate
meeting only to
um not hear when the gun is dropped on
the floor as a means of surrender during
a demonstration
what was supposed to be a fun demo of
technology to help the office get over
that 2pm feeling
turns into a deadly assault on some poor
stiff and then
there's dick jones while the victim's
body is still
warm says it's only a glitch man
those suits are really focused on the
bottom line dick
i'm very disappointed dick jones has a
fitting demise from that very same
office that is fairly cathartic
but not before his boy clarence
botticker has a ball from start to
finish
whether he's breaking up a classic 80s
coke party or asking one of his minions
can you fly bobby dude relishes every
moment he has
and it makes it so much fun for the
audience while both films have more than
their share of moments we remember
it's the dark humor of robocop that
separates it from the pack
come quietly or there will be trouble
ah [ __ ] you terminator holds up
incredibly well as a horror sci-fi
action hybrid and much of that staying
power is due to the lead performances
and james cameron honing his craft the
nightclub scene where sarah realizes
just how fearsome her foe
is remains an intensely thrilling
sequence however i have to give the edge
to robocop here simply because the movie
vacillates so
smoothly between a great action flick a
frightening harbinger of the world we're
about to live in
and a genius satire mocking our own
modern lifestyles
and every facet comes with its own set
of iconic moments
thank you for your cooperation good
night
i'll buy that for a dollar
robocop takes this round ties the ball
game and now we head into the wild card
round with a little bit of trash talk
your move creep and now it's time for
the wild card round
sequel lightest if it is indeed the
terminators move
robocop ain't gonna like what's coming
while some might question the fairness
or legality of having film sequels weigh
in on a battle between two original
works of art
let's be honest one championship is
great but only by consistently winning
over the course of a career
can champions be considered a dynasty
and unfortunately for alex murphy his
inaugural flick was the peak of his
alter ego robocop's success
but despite robocop 2's multiple plot
misfires
the film still raked in 99 million
dollars when it was released in 1990
not bad for a child nuke dealer robocop
3 would effectively end the original
franchise's hopes of continuing beyond
the 1990s as its 1993 release
only netted 24 million dollars even more
disappointing
might have been the middling 66 million
bucks that the reboot of robocop made in
2014.
hey i didn't hate it i had some fun with
that iteration love michael keaton and i
didn't lose my mind and it was rated
pg-13 instead of the hard r of the
originals
but keep in mind in 1987 robocop
had to pass through the mpaa multiple
times just to get down to an r
rating it was originally rated x which
sounds
so much cooler and dangerous than
today's nc-17
none of the sequels or reboots or tv
show attempts yes
tv show attempts got close to fresh on
the tomato meter
in fact the closest any of them got to
that patch was 2014's robocop which
landed at 48
on the tomato meter and 49 on the
audience score
i was one of those boating it up but
alas my mission failed
i'm so sorry but i thought your suit
looked cool
meanwhile in the future the war against
the machines raged on
and produced one of the best sequels
ever made nay
one of the best movies of all time hands
down
period drop the mic don't send anyone
back in time to kill me
before t2 was released judgment day was
a concept
hinted at in the bible referenced in
ghostbusters
and it's a pretty cool van halen tune
but ever since its release in the summer
of 1991
judgment day has become synonymous with
the star and director
at the peak of their fame and
storytelling powers if terminator 2
came by your apartment it wouldn't even
have to ask you'd willingly give it your
clothes your boots
and your motorcycle somehow it's less
than the perfect score of its
predecessor on the tomato meter
checking in at 93 percent and then 94
on the audience score but hey remember
how the first terminator grossed over
100 million dollars and we're like
wow terminator 2 did 441 million
dollars here in the states and that
helped 2003's rise of the machines
and 2009's salvation also forged
impressive numbers
one could accurately equate the most
recent terminator sequels
jenny smith and dark fate with the way
to robo cops
are you kidding me although at least
dark fate had one more badass
sarah connor turned by linda hamilton
and it's always fun to see arnold do
arnold things
but if those two movies alone make
things equal there's just no shot for
robocop to topple the might of
terminator 2 judgement day
it is just such a great movie maybe it
was the satirical angle of robocop that
felt its chances of continued box office
and
audience dominance after all history has
proven that comedy sequels are the
hardest to pull off of any genre
wayne's world 2 and the naked gun 2 and
a half are unfortunately outliers
the norm would be dumb and dumber 2 son
of the mask or
god forbid caddyshack 2. talking about
judgment day
yikes humor was the special sauce that
made robocop stand out from the pack
and the sequels just couldn't find the
right blend by the time robocop 3 came
out
it was just a mere farce spoofing itself
as much as anything else
but us audiences never get tired of a
good time travel
epic back to the future i had two solid
sequels and we even welcomed bill and
ted back with open arms to face the
music
in 2020 action franchises like die hard
bad boys and
fine transformers continue to rake in
cash even if the critical returns aren't
as lucrative
and yes the law of diminishing returns
certainly applies to terminator films
it's the peak of t2 that deserves to
still be celebrated and it's the biggest
reason why
terminator takes this round and thus
wins the match
your move creep [ __ ] you [ __ ]
so there you have it one guy in a cool
jacket's take on robocop versus
terminator
i'd rather go back and enjoy murphy than
arnold if we're just talking the
originals
but both have earned their rightful
place at the forefront of experimental
progressive
risk-taking 1980 cinema they didn't rest
on their neat robot laurels when they
easily could have
instead both terminator and robocop took
chances
made bold moves and ended up giving the
world to legendary characters but again
that's just my take
now it's your turn hit me up on social
media with your winner and defend your
answer with bigger
i'm at mark ellis live the team here is
at rotten tomatoes
and taking us out is neither arnold or
peter weller it's the true hero of these
[Music]
movies
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign